et ne pas juger c'était aussi en quelque
sorte la devise du commissaire maigret
bien faisons comme eux ne jugeons pas
georges simenon essayant de le
comprendre
écoutant le parler de ses enfants de ces
femmes de ses livres de lui même dans
ses mémoires intimes qui viennent de
paraître aux presses de la cité
il dit tout il dit tout y compris le
bonheur et la détresse et le dis sans
forcer la voix mais avec ce que l'on
pourrait appeler le l'impudeur de la
franchise c'est un livre qu'on attendait
pas et qui va surprendre qui va choquer
probablement mais rappelons nous que
dans tous ses romans
georges simenon essaye de mettre l'homme
à nu eh bien cette fois le menu c'est
lui ce soir face à la vérité face à sa
vérité
[Musique]
maman
oh
[Musique]
jean sinon il y à 7 ans quasiment jour
pour jour j'étais ici même dans votre
maison de lausanne en suisse j'étais en
face de vous pour un court entretien
télévisé et j'avais été frappé à ce
moment là par votre quiétude par votre
sérénité parce qu'on pourrait peut-être
appeler sur deux bonnes heures dans la
vieillesse
ils étaient inimaginables à ce moment là
que vous puissiez écrire et publier ce
livre terrible intitulé mémoires intimes
alors que s'est il passé entre temps
mais il s'est passé beaucoup
d'événements y compris surtout un
événement capital pendant ma vie c'est
l'amour de ma fille j'ai vécu toute ma
vie pour mes enfants c'est ce qui m'a
intéressé le plus c'est ce qui m'a
passionné plusieurs ma vie au point que
avant bien avant il ya des années quand
on me demandait un journaliste moment de
ma profession je répondais père de
famille dont je peux dire que j'ai suivi
mes enfants depuis jour de la naissance
j'ai assisté à l'accouchement chaque
fois bien dès ce moment là je les
suivais en essayant de comprendre ce
qu'ils allaient devenir en essayant de
comprendre leur caractère j'ai fait
aussi bien pour mes garçons que pour
m'enrichir longtemps vous avez trois
garçons une fille et la fille c'est
l'avant dernière c'est l'abandon mais
elle est morte et s'est suicidé le cfi
et ça évidemment c'est un drame pour un
pêche a été un drame épouvantable
au début j'ai été complètement écrasées
je vais que plusieurs mois vraiment
écrasé ma région à d'ailleurs voulu non
par ce dernier je veux être incinérés et
que ce cendres soient répandues dans le
jardin
teresa et moi l'avons fait un matin tous
les deux elle est toujours avec nous
mais depuis lors petit à petit c'est
devenu cette douleur s'est adoucie et je
ne dirais pas que je suis retourné à la
sérénité
mais ma région vient avec nous tirait
bien nous en parlons
tous les deux comme c'est vraiment elle
était encore là et j'ai retrouvé une
certaine sérénité
mais ce livre là vous l'avez crise et
pour la faire revivre c'est aussi pour
prouver notre amour qui est
effectivement immense pour elle et c'est
aussi me semble-t-il la volonté chez
vous 2 de dire aussi que vous l'avez
beaucoup aimé qu'elle vous a beaucoup
aimé et que si elle est morte ce n'est
quand même pas de votre faute
c'était pas de mots font rien du tout au
contraire
d'ailleurs ces lettres à ses dernières
lettres ces derniers messages
ces derniers coûtent téléphone etc à le
pot nettement j'ai toute une caisse de
lettres à des lieux de culte mordelles
car elle garde et où elles avaient tous
classés et elle m'avait presque fait
promettre qu'un jour la signature ce sur
la même couverture à la fin de vos
mémoires intimes effectivement 100 pages
sont consacrées à des textes de marie jo
des lettres qu'elle vous adresser des
poèmes qu'elle a écrit des chansons
qu'elle fait cela dont elle a écrit les
textes des textes de cassettes que vous
en voyez c'est un caractère étrange mari
joue parce que elle a peu tâté de toutes
les professions artistiques
oui elle avait elle été tentée par tout
ce qui est extérieur isation artistique
si je puis dire parce que la réponse
n'est jamais qu'une extériorisation
sénat en juin je parle de l'art vraiment
le créateur ccdh a besoin
je n'ai jamais écrit dans une visée
comment dirais-je ni moral ni
philosophique ni quoi que ce soit
esthétique mais vraiment pour me sentir
le mans mène bien ma région verse même
besoin dès son enfance
dès son enfance elle a pris des cours de
dessin des cours de peinture des cours
de danse de danses de toutes sortes de
l'électron veines et réécrivait
énormément disons les choses carrément
elle a été traumatisée par des faits
qu'elle est traumatisée et certainement
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas pu lui éviter
ces sites félin et lancement et si gdr
ma région sa liberté presque complète
même complète comme je les aime les
enfants d'ailleurs à mes fils jamais je
n'ai poussant de mes enfants dans telle
ou telle direction
je les ai choisi d aider à choisir
eux-mêmes j'ai servi de garde-fou autant
je n'ai pu mais dans le cas de ma région
lorsqu'elle est partie j'ai continuer à
la soutenir autant que j'ai pu mais les
psychiatres même d'écouter vos louisfert
le referiez plus de mal on comment
dirais-je en exerçant un pouvoir
quelconque sauval élargirait de sa
liberté entière
sané comme ça qu'elle peut comment
dirais-je se ressaisir
il ya eu des moments où elle avait une
lucidité parfaite
oui mais on la voit bien dans ses textes
et on la voit bien telle que vous la
décrivez elle est instable
elle est mal dans sa peau dorée elle
exige trop d'elle-même elle exige trop
de la vie comment vivre
aurais-je pu faire uniquement ces faits
qui ont été dramatiques dans sa vie par
exemple la découverte de la sexualité
avait quelque chose d'effrayant
effroyable d'effroyables mais je préfère
ne pas rentrer vient de bien on ne va
pas en parler
d'ailleurs je n'en ai pas encore parlé
moi même mais j'ai donné simplement un
document de ma région elle-même c'est là
qu'il rencontre les allemands
il ya aussi le fait que l été elle
comprenait pas très bien vos relations
avec teresa au début elle était jalouse
on va rejouer comme beaucoup de filles
adorait son père est bien marré jo vous
l'êtes vous voulez que je sois à elle
seule les gens oui mais elle voulait
tout mais c'est un amour quasiment
excessive quelques qu'elle vous porte
écouter les textes a sous les yeux vous
appelle daddy ou dad
à 23 ans et vous écrit ceci je voulais
tant de choses lorsque j'étais petit de
pureté d'amour de soleil dans mes yeux
avec les grands bras fort d'inde a dit
rien qu'à moi j'aurais voulu da dit
donnez l'univers tous qui frémissait
dans le fond de mon coeur la chaleur
d'un amour partagé avec toi et puis ceci
encore c'est vrai j'étais petit je
n'avais que sept ans mais je jouais ta
femme
et j'oubliais et maman et et d'autres
textes encore voici celui là que tu as
fait extraordinaire et de sentir dans
les yeux d'un autre de son père un peu
d'amour que par pudeur on appelle
affection et puis que par pudeur on
appelle même plus rien on oublie on ne
peut plus dire je t'aime parce que c'est
d'un autre temps c'est fait pour des
femmes c'est fait pour des amants
alors on dit je t'aime beaucoup tu sais
ce petit tu sais c'est pour cacher le
beaucoup et puis pour cacher le j'ai osé
dire je t'aime et mais justement saborit
à l'incident de l'alliance un jour
lorsqu'elle avait 8 ou 9 en effet est
venu en ville avec moi je venais souvent
mes lecteurs c'est moi qu'elle habille
les chez les marchands de vêtements pour
enfants etc
j'ai toujours habillé j'ai toujours
acheté tout ce qu'il lui fallait
et un jour elle me dit je voudrais bien
de petites bagues et nous sommes entrés
chez un bijoutier est alors mieux
montrer les petites bagues l'enfant
qu'une petite pierre bleue claire vous
savez et elle a dit non je veux la même
que l'année dernière une alliance
à noter même pas encore connaître le nom
je le suppose d'une alliance qui réunion
cette bague on a dû d'ailleurs guerrette
ensérune et jusqu'à sa mort la porte et
aidants sont ces derniers vu dans son
dernier testament elle ne recommande
surtout de veiller après 120 génération
que sa bague soit encore là et qu'elle
soit répandue avec une accélération
famex décembre une lettre qu'il écrit un
amant et il termine cette par cette
phrase tu sais je t'aime peut être
autant que mon père et c'est plus que je
ne pourrai jamais en dire à quelqu'un et
ceci aussi donc c'est un petit peu la
jalousie il ne comprend pas la place de
teresa est là là c'est votre témoignage
à vous comme teresa nous a laissé seuls
à son habitude tu me regardes presque
durement et j'ai peur de comprendre
c'est que c'est vous qui vous et qui
manie qui dit samarie joues tu me dis en
effet comme étouffante colère pourquoi
elle et pas moi tu ne comprends pas ma
fille comprendre quoi je te désigne le
lit teresa partage tout de ma vie et
alors elle vous répond ceci est alors
est alors que voulez vous que je fasse
quand même offert ma classe
j'étais bien obligé de dire non tout
nous mêmes je ne pouvais pas en faire ma
compagne de 24 heures par jour puis
encore ce texte de marie jo gens sinon
que vous citez avec beaucoup de
franchise dans votre livre
je réalise pleinement maintenant combien
j'étais égoïste je te voulait toi tout
seul ouvert à moi quand je l'avais
besoin disponible à mes caprices de
petite fille je demandais exclusivement
monde had je l'admets t'es pas l'homme
d'un autre amour j'alerte accusé d'adp
n'en est rien si je devais accuser
quelqu'un ce serait d'abord moi et mon
incompréhension ma jalousie mon égoïsme
dorénavant j'accepterai mieux teresa et
et puis elle jusque le disais tout à
l'heure et une exigence de la vie réelle
demande trop à la vie est là aussi et ce
texte qui est superbe au seigneur je
suis réellement persuadé que ce que
j'essaie d'obtenir dans cette [ __ ] de
vie n'existe pas oui elle vole un amour
total
elle voulait union totale avec moi je ne
pouvais pas chauve et lui remet tout le
monde l'amour toute ma tendresse mais je
ne pouvais tout de même pas allé jusqu'à
la mort physique
vous avez gardé évidemment très pieuse
mans c'est le mot je crois tout ça
correspond tout ces cassettes et le est
ce que est ce que cette trop pénible
pour vous de d'écouter la voix de marie
jo parce que non mais écoutez j'ai fait
resté deux ans sans pouvoir l'écouter
j'ai déjà fait hier éloigné de la maison
et même de bons secrétaires je l'avait
donné à son psychiatre pour le jour où
je serai capable de les réentendre et
maintenant j'en suis capable
à peu près est ce que je pourrais est ce
que nous pourrions ce que les
téléspectateurs pourraient entendre un
texte qui est très beau qui s'appelle l'
angoisse et que je crois vous avez
enregistré madame angot madame
angoissant l'âme humaine à m'angoisser
on peut dire sans la nuit alors si on
peut le entendre de la musique au ras du
sol
mon cahier par terre juste en dessous et
puis par dessus mon corps couché à plat
ventre est bien mon corps attendez je
tâte
oui oui je crois pas du moins ils
ressemblent même examiner de près la
lumière car j'ai la lumière là dans le
coin derrière le haut parleur
elle nous éclaire tout où tous les trois
la musique le cahier moi pardon
toutes les excuses tous les cadres
devrais-je dire moi je pu oublier
oui comment et pourquoi m ressaisie
alors qu'enfin j'avais réussi à ignorer
sa présence
enfin cet empire bien hélas beaucoup
trop même à croire qu'il n'y en a
vraiment que pour elle je parle
vous ne savez pas je parle de mon
angoisse mais vous ne la connaissez pas
vous en avez de la chance bien mais
c'est qu'il faut que je vous présente
excusez moi je vous en prie elle se
réveille c'est autrement vous savez et
bien voilà non maintenant que c'est fait
vous vous défilez pas comme ça vous
savez pas fuir quand même que vous avez
peur peur de mon angoisse mais c'est
l'édicule voyons vous savez vous
vous ne pourriez pas avoir plus peur qu
elle sursauta mal à elle est vraiment
imbattable moi-même tenait depuis le
temps ce n'est pas réussi à faire mieux
du côté des très sain pas moyen de de la
bad un degré
c'est à croire mon coeur
je sais pas
mais puis
et mme ausculte
et puis
pis elle tremble je tremble aussi
comment je me dis qu'en merde 30
puisqu'elles pourront pas du tout au
rien à faire ma contrôler des fois
pareil même chose c'est pas drôle c'est
une fois au fou au moins que j'étais sur
un terrain où je pensais pouvoir charmer
doivent pas non à rien à faire mais
vous savez
plus pas vraiment sa faute
pour la planète née au début je m'étais
lire
d'accord je vais les cacher ni me roy
puis miroir elle aura peut-être moins
peur parce que c'est peut-être comme les
animaux l'angoissent voit dans la glace
et puis et puis ça prend peur parce que
ça c'est pas très bien ce que c'est
alors plus de miroirs plus rien puis je
la vois là dans le coin piano chauffe
tranquille comme moi et puis
quelque chose qui me frappe tout d'un
coup je dis bien mais qu'est ce que
c'est
c'étaient les murs enfin c'était un des
murs va pas vraiment un mur mais retenez
imaginer elle était toute seule elle
avait pas de miroir et bien il a fallu
quand même qu'elle projette sur le mur
l'image qu'elle avait d'elle-même et
pin's est revenue seulement ça s'est un
peu trompé de direction à sa mère tombée
sur la figure alors là j'ai évidemment
j'ai pas apprécié parce que bon bah elle
avait qu'à être objective parce qu'il
paraît que quand le tir et quand le
renvoi après le renvoi je veux dire de
du transfert est subjectif ça peut
tromper de se tromper de trajectoire
alors bon je comprends mais c'est s
était pas la première fois qu est ce que
je peux en prendre leur plein la tête
bon après si je pars avec elle parce que
c'est un texte de synthèse qui fait peur
avec tout cet extérieur transmise au
mobbing et était complètement improvisé
et n'a jamais rien préparé elle
m'envoyait des lettres comme ça
entièrement improvisée y est même ses
chansons nous avons eu de la peine est
de produire et entendre plusieurs fois
pour les taper à la machine pour les
maîtres blancs sont noirs parce que noir
sur blanc parce que jamais mais elle dit
dans un de ses textes que en fait le
dernier texte qu'elle vous a écrit juste
avant de mourir avant de se suicider
elle dit aux fonds qu'elles meurent par
dignité
oui et si je comprends bien ce mot ça
veut dire qu'elle n'a pas voulu être
devant vous quelqu'un qui rate sa vie
qui rate ce que quelqu'un qui rate ce
qu'il entreprend que je ne crois pas non
d'après le psychiatre qui le plus
j'en parle d'ailleurs le professeur
diront qu'il a connu dès l'âge de 12 ans
eagle a été héroïque
elle a fait ce qu'elle devait faire
parce que elle sera les devants une vie
épouvantables et dit il à l amphi geste
qu'elle a vécu en 25 ans dit elle une
vie plus plein que les gens de 75 dans
mon vécu et comment expliquez-vous ce
mot dignité
je ne sais pas elle a parlé n'y avait
même plus et que certaines je m'excuse
j'ose à peine touchée à cet extra parce
que ça me bouleverse toujours malgré
tout limité peut-être parce qu'on ne
voulait pas retourner dans les cliniques
elle en a parlé d'ailleurs de ces dures
en clinique la raconter ce que c'était
et je crois qu'elle est considérée sam
c'est justement commune la dignité de
devenir un objet manié par le
d'infirmières par les médecins et le
post scriptum à sa dernière lettre at on
le droit de disperser un peu descendre
dans la nature pour ne pas rester
prisonnière complètement dans dû fermer
mais retrouver levante et c3 d'animaux
poésie sans doute mais vous allez voir
georges simenon comme on se fait des
idées fausses sur les gens qu'on connaît
mal mais c'est que moi j'étais persuadé
que eu égard au nombre de livres vous
avez publié vous avez écrit je me disais
georges simenon sûrement jamais occupé
de ses enfants parce qu'il avait bien
d'autres choses à faire et puis quand on
lit ce livre c'est au contraire et ça a
été la passion de ma visite est la
passion de votre vie mais surtout j'ai
dû attendre longtemps parce que ma
famille et des peintres ne voulait pas
d'enfant en tout cas ce moment là a
remarqué qu'elle m'a peut-être un rendu
un grand service parcs un jardin n'est
pas une enfant tout en étant marié qui
gît que je joue encore d'ailleurs que je
suis un très long terme offrant un peu
d'étrangers à mon service parce que vous
jouez des enfants j'aimerais peut-être
traîner avec moi à travers le monde
qu'on me l'ait fait un carton je voulais
courir le monde pour connaître l'homme
j'aurais fait comme avec marca le pour
marc lui céline aura été de séné débile
quand il avait 6 ans et il a été traîné
à travers toute l'amérique et à un cul
tantôt en arizona tantôt en californie
et en floride
quant au vin partout et qui vous lisez
dans des craintes que je vais pouvoir ne
pas changer d'école et garder les mêmes
petits amis c'est ce qu'ils disent c'est
ça quand il avait 7 ans un peu fan vous
êtes toujours été plus soucieux la
carrière de vos enfants que la carrière
de romans aux régions le sujet me soucie
de la carrière lemay roman on irait
légende est tout seul car il est moi qui
se vendait tout seul ben oui mais je
n'en suis vraiment je n'ai jamais rien
fait pour cela et si j'écris ça et si je
me suis mis à nu c'est parce que
ensemble c'est la suite de pedigree ça
j'ai écrit pedigree 1 42 ans
ah oui pourquoi ça c'est intéressant
bien équipée degree parce que je croyais
que j'allais mourir médecins plus ou
moins marron d'ailleurs on avait annoncé
que j'en avais pour deux ans vivre à
condition de ne plus travailler de ne
plus faire aucun exercice de mes temps
au moins six heures par jour en lui de
ne plus avoir de relation physique avec
une femme croit toujours
sinon je mourrai dont marc avait à ce
moment là deux ans je ne finis tiens
voilà un petit garçon qui ne connaîtra
jamais sa famille ne sera jamais qui
était son père son grand psg tenté
saison complète ses terres et j'ai
commencé à écrire à la main
mon petit mars j'avais émis d'ailleurs
pedigree canadian généalogique sera sur
la couverture et nord des cahiers comme
j'ai écrit ce livre aussi j'ai commencé
en ce moment là gallimard passe et ils
me disent que je peux apporter une copie
du manuscrit pour le montrer c'était
pendant la guerre moi je n'avais pas le
droit de passer dans ligne comme
étrangers
meliani mère pouvait le faire c'était
claude d'ailleurs en ce moment là et ils
la portent et harry qui m'a écrit
surtout arrêter ça mais écrivait le sous
forme de roman fin accrue et le coma
roman pendant la première personne
et j'ai écrit de pedigree qui apparurent
en volume comme celui là derrière ou à
peu près et le pedigree aller jusque 15
ans 16 ans et j'y disais exactement la
vérité et des vérités aussi cru et je ne
ménagerai pas plus que dans ce livre là
si bien que ceux ci me reprend depuis
l'âge de 16 ans et reprend toute cette
vie et si il ya des choses qui
choqueront certainement qu'on
considérera comme indécente et cetera je
vous répondrai très franchement que
j'aimais mieux chez menus être critiquée
même être détesté pour ce que je suis
vraiment que d'être aimé ou admirée pour
chaque je ne suis pas ce livre là vous
l'avez écrit pour vous pour vos quatre
enfants et vous adresser d'ailleurs
toujours à 1 toujours je m'adresse un
chacun je me rappelle d'une page à
l'autre
alors on se dit pourquoi finalement
d'avoir publié ce livre
écoutez je vais reprendre un
raisonnement que je crois très simple et
a pour l'instant plus de 40 pieds
graphie ils ont passé qu'il est apparu
seront à travers le monde un peu dans
tous les pays
c'est un petit peu fatigant alors j'ai
voulu tout le même donner temps je fais
encore vivant ma vérité à moi peu
importe est que les gens la juge un peu
cru mais j'ai voulu dire la vraie vérité
je ne suis pas le phénomène le phénomène
peut en enjeu rats quand on m'appelle le
phénomène est si benoît ou l'énigme et
souligne un phénomène est une énigme
je suis tout simplement l'artisan qui a
fait son métier pendant plus de 65 ans
et c'est tout elle ce sera mon dernier
livre publié
j'en écrirai j'écris encore quand je
crois j'ai besoin d'écrire comme un
artisan bien travaillé ces outils
jusqu'à la fin de ses jours même si
c'est pour bricoler je bricole rares
gore mais je ne peux bien curieusement
vivre en somme
j'ai voulu donner maroc marc vérité
hélas oui oui le vous avez été vous un
enfant de pauvre
est-ce qu aux enfants on était quatre
enfants de riches et je regrette pauvres
parce que enfin j'aurais préféré qu'ils
commencent comme moi pour qu'ils ne
soient pas conduire à l'école en rolls
royce ou en jaguar et c'est hamilton etc
et vous comment il tenait qu'à vous
c'est très difficile parce que avec
l'engrenage de ma vie avec l'engrenage
de mes obligations de tous les gens que
j'avais recevoir etc
j'ai été obligé d'avoir des grandes
maisons en page
j'ai tout essayé j'ai vécu il a fallu
que je connaisse tous les milieux et
quatre sorties peau j'ai connu tous les
milieux et j'ai connu aussi bien de très
grands de ce monde je n'attends pas du
tout je le contraire avec les mémoires
la plupart des écrivains je ne parle pas
des gens que j'ai rencontrés réchauffe d
arles thèse des grands bancs y est c'est
ea et on a même acquis j'ai refusé la
porte de ma maison de très grands
banquiers qui me demandait pouvoir faire
ma connaissance ce jour de nous demander
de l'argent n'était pas vraiment de
larges banderoles buts offerts mais les
fusées je n'ai refusé de la recevoir une
question encore un peu discret dessus à
propos de vos enfants vous les fait
baptiser tous les 4 alors que vous ne
croyez ni à dieu ni au diable une raison
très simple c'est que lorsque
me suis mariée pour la première fois il
faut dire que je ne crois pas en arrière
je suis même très l'adversaire enfin
lorsque je me suis mariée pour la
première fois avec thé j'ai donc ma
première femme elle était tout à fait
religieux zh et même presque vraiment
hâte et toute sa famille l'été
ma mère était extrêmement catholique et
ma mère aurait été en aurait fait une
maladie si je ne mettais pas marié
religieux religieuses et alors je me
suis aperçu que c'est très compliqué il
a fallu pendant deux mois
la pauvreté j'ai tous les soirs chez les
curés pour prendre des leçons de
catéchisme et il a fallu qu'elle fasse
sa première commune sa première
communion sa première confession sa
confirmation
enfin tout le tralala en un mois rue
alors c'était tout de même marie-laure
je suis dispo tout ça pour arriver à
meylan sont entrés jamais qui vont une
pesée alors pourquoi paraît faire
baptiser
c'est une formalité mon dieu nous avons
bien ramé ray c'est aussi lieu dans
l'amérique d'aléas les guides
pourquoi faut-il attendre d'un hummer ou
ou de lanzhou et et puis pourquoi
n'assister vous pas au mariage de vos
enfants
je ne sus pour mariage des enfants parce
que je ne crois par l'ohm arrière et
vous êtes marié de voir comment vous
êtes mariée deux fois la deuxième fois
où c'était pour que qui est jonnie le
zoulou ne soit pas allé en farine on met
les raisons sont excellentes mais
n'empêche vous êtes marié deux fois il
voulait pas assister au mariage de vos
enfants
alors là et il ya une raison autre c'est
que si j'avais assisté au mariage demain
qui aurait deux personnes qui seraient
rencontrés c'était ma première balle
deuxième femme et comme en ce moment là
elle se serait arraché les yeux je n'ai
pas pu aller neigeux va alors je ne veux
pas faire d'exception plus je ne suis
pas
un renard jeune héros mariage donc
puisque vous me invité georges simenon
parlant des femmes
il ya trois femmes qui ont un joué un
rôle peut le dire très important dans
votre vie alors chronologiquement en
trois tranches de huit complet alors la
première régine renchon des tiji
j'appelais toujours tj parce que régine
ça me semblait tout le même un peu sur
la nel salamone jeunesse comment c'était
de toutes celles premier amour de
jeunesse c'est à dire où je reporte eh
oui sur la une femme tous les rêves
qu'un jeune homme de 20 ans car j'étais
est fiancée à 17 ans elle un petit
mariama williams et vous étiez
journaliste à 15 ans j'ai des gens de la
deuxième chance et ça va prendre
alors vous êtes vous a été mariée avec
cette femme dont vous avez eu un enfant
ses marques
oui vous avez été marié avec elle
pendant pendant 20 ans alors après
arrivent les utilise en selle alors ça
c'est l'amour fou de votre audience non
c'est par amour fou c'est la passion la
passion je considère la passion comme
d'ailleurs les psychiatres et les
médecins comme une maladie la passion
est une maladie qui peut même arriver à
rendre fou quand on dit foot passion
il ya d'ailleurs beaucoup beaucoup de
crimes qui ont été commis par passion eh
bien ça a été quelquefois moins une que
j'en arrive une passion ce quelque chose
d'irrésistible et qui vous échappe
complètement
alors ça c'est une canadienne vous avez
rencontré à new york
j'ai rencontré alan new york est la même
nuit nous étions l'amour est dans le pré
nom et denise et que vous avez épousé
qui vous a donné trois enfants qui m'a
donné trois offres
c'est sa mère elle semble évolue
d'ailleurs enfin en temps jean loup
c'était rien fait pour qu'il ne soit pas
là britney je l'avais prévenu dès que
j'ai rencontré d'abord que n est pas
elle jalouse parce que je verrai autant
de femmes que je voudrais deuxièmement
que je ne voudrais jamais mais vous
dites bien épouser je l'épousé pour deux
raisons d'abord pour que johnny son
enfant légitime et ensuite parce que
j'aurais été expulsés de la mairie si je
ne l'avais pas fait
et puis la troisième c'était raisin est
la troisième s'intéresse à essence est
venu tranquillement lentement teresa
vécu dans notre intimité les moments les
plus dramatiques de cette passion-là et
où j'en étais arrivé vraiment d'ailleurs
ce sont les psychiatres qui s'en sont
occupés ça n'est pas moi elle a été
plusieurs fois en maison de santé de sa
propre volonté d'ailleurs pas du tout de
la scène comme elle le prétend des
réserves a assisté à tous âges étaient
complètement désemparé j'étais une
chiffe molle et j'étais pas me suicider
et si je n'ai pas vrai c'est grave la
suisse ira theresa qui a été jusqu'à
retirer de la maison toutes les
cartouches
il y avait paul le revolver qu'est le
fusil 22 qui existait dans la maison
elle si je suis encore du nom
aujourd'hui c'est grâce à cela et notre
amour est venu petit à petit et là j'ai
connu le véritable ce j'appelle
véritable home c'est à dire
l'intégration de zz qui n'en compte
qu'un et qui font une chose d'ailleurs
que je crois serra 7 capable de vie
pendant près de 20 ans 24 heures sur 24
ensemble
connaissez vous beaucoup de coupes c'est
grâce à mon métier évidemment que je
peux le faire mais
beaucoup de groupes qui sont capables de
vivre 24 heures sur 24 ensemble sans
jamais se quitter
lorsque j'ai chez le médecin des avec
moi lorsqu'il vouloir aller chez le
médecin même gynécologue je devais avec
elle déjà tendance à la date
oui mais vous rencontrez teresa vous
êtes déjà un homme assez âgé et vous
n'êtes plus vous n'allez peut mener pas
20 ans n'est pas le cas valeur
extraordinaire pour raconter dans votre
mémoire
pardon pardon au début teresa a connu
toute mésaventure car j'en ai encore eu
longtemps et notre amour est aussi
charnel que spirituelle ou affectif je
ne sais pas comment vous entendez ça il
ya un autre personnage aussi qu'ici qui
vous suit tout au long de votre vie qui
s'appelle bull bull bull l'avons
rencontrée avec tj après un an de
mariage nous étions les passer des
vacances à être ta chez une amie et chez
cet ami avec bull qui avait débuté dans
la vie elles étaient des travailleurs à
12 ans a gardé les enfants et nous avons
décidé comme non par notre ami ne
l'utilisais clé été pendant deux mois sa
vie de la taille des batailles devant
décidé d'embaucher bull et boucle a fait
partie de mauduit
mais quand il devient ainsi partie de ma
vie intime
dès le premier mois et la continuer et
nous sommes encore dans le meilleur
rapport et bull vient de voir deux fois
par an comme d'ailleurs je suis resté
très ami avec qui j qu'est venu le voir
ya à peu près six mois comme vous dites
la vérité dans ce livre on dit comme des
scènes qui sont stupéfiantes
vous avez écrit un roman qui s'appelle
trois chambres à manhattan mais j'ai
envie de dire que vous auriez pu écrire
un livre s'appelle trois femmes à tucson
à ce moment vous habitez à tucson c'est
dans le connecticut je croise était donc
songer même tour
et vous aviez l'épousé légitime vous
aviez la scène votre maîtresse antilles
qui va devenir votre femme vous avez
vous avez bull qui est aussi la haie et
vous temps en temps vous allez quand
même au bordel
mais si si mais je vous dirais
d'ailleurs à ce point de vue là que je
considère les prostituées comme des
femmes comme les autres j'ai horreur des
mots employés par exemple ouzou et la
plupart des gens en emploi pour les pour
les nommer et j'en ai connu d'humilier
et je vous assure que beaucoup d'entre
elles sombrent plus digne quelquefois
que certaines femmes mariées j'ai trouvé
chez malgré beaucoup plus oui oui et je
trouvais même beaucoup plus
d'affectivité quelquefois les strip
teaseuses par exemple j'ai beaucoup
fréquenté
eh bien d'abord parce qu'elles ont de
beaux corps et deuxièmement parce que
c'était possible miens gens ne trouvent
et qui était vraiment de femme
extraordinaire est il vrai qu'on m'a
rapporté
est il vrai que vous ayez dit que vous
avez connu charnellement dix mille
femmes
ça c'est une histoire amusante n'est pas
un jour fellini viens moi nous sommes
très amis avec lui depuis très longtemps
depuis 20 ans nous sommes lamy et
féminine était venu c'était un long
moment du lancement de casanova et y mon
fils johnny en ce moment là était chez
lui au monde a été chargé de faire le
lancement en france de casanova alors et
vous depuis prenez sur un magnétophone
notre conversation à bâtons rompus avec
fellini alors on s'est mis bien entendu
à parler de casanova on sait faire mieux
mais on s'est mis à parler de femmes et
fument 10 15 en oeuvre a eu quatre mille
et quelques femmes juste du voyons il a
vécu combien d'années y temps je dis ça
en fait un pas une tare joue justement
j'en ai en général trois par jour depuis
l'âge de 13 ans alors si je faisais le
calcul je ne sais pas ce que ça
donnerait et je ne sais plus et lui
aussi c'est moi qui habite à ou des
mines ans au moins
peut-elle je n'en sais rien je n'ai pas
compté et de la laddh et de la légende
dans tous les pays du monde c'est
maintenant l'heure de dix mille femmes
c'est les cockers parle plus et ça
m'ennuie pas du tout sur le jeune femme
je ne me suis jamais vanté je ne suis
pas un comment dire est un sportif qui
veut absolument à 6 comme elle attrape
moi si tu ne peux pas battre comme enfin
on sent quand même il ya chez vous temps
en temps quand même la passion du don
juan ou du casanova collectionneur a pas
du tout du tout et à mesure ait dit oui
il ya un certain nombre de gens qui ont
ce besoin physique lorsque j'avais 15 16
ans vous parler lorsque j'étais
journaliste et qu'à liège je me l'étais
je me trouve un revêtement des géants
pantalon de toile fine vous savez de
kamardine très fines dans un tram v et
que je foley une femme sur la plateforme
du tram vais je ne savais comment sortir
parce que j'étais un des sens et je
devais me précipiter lorsque vous
appelez à bordes
je n'en peux rien c'est un jour il ya
beaucoup d'individus comme moi n'y a pas
que moi mais on a l'impression que de
temps en temps pour vous faire l'amour
ça n'a pas plus d'importance il manque
de vous moucher aussi aussi j'ai
toujours cherché à comprendre les gens
et bien et à av
comment dirais-je à m'associer à aller
je ne dirais pas répéter mais par ait
pénétré étant donné ce que je vais dire
mais je crois tout de même que l'union
la plus possible qu'on peut avoir en
deux aides
c'est encore celle là c'est encore de
faire l'amour je ne crois pas qu'ils
aient de communication reprend beaucoup
de communication maintenant eh bien
c'est pas avec des mots qu'on communique
très mal avec les mots les mots peuvent
servir à tous tandis que là il ya
vraiment une communication directe et
j'avais faim j'avais faim de la femme et
de toutes les femmes et je me disais
mais c'est malheureux parce que en
attaque quand il dit que je ne
connaîtrais pas
koné serait pas physiquement ce livre
mémoires intimes georges simenon c'est
aussi l'histoire d'une passion
vous avez évoqué il ya un moment d une
passion qui s'effiloche qui se délite et
qui qui va jusqu'à tomber dans dans les
abîmes de l'alcoolisme de la psychiatrie
ça vous avez voulu raconter aussi oui et
je me sentais depuis le début parce
qu'il faut dire que le jour où j'ai
rencontré le mal on sait qu'elle va les
spécialistes alors il s'agit de toujours
de denise mais pourquoi l'appeler vous
des vous mettez juste des parce que
selon me gêne maintenant pour les
moindres non et c'est le plus vous
n'êtes plus pendant elle n'existe plus
pauvres
donc nous dirons alors mais je vous
dirais une chose j'ai un trait de
caractère et je connais bien c'est que
je suis une sorte de saint bernard
j'essaye toujours d'aider quelqu'un
quand je vois quelqu'un en difficulté
j'essaie de l'aider
au fond je savais dès le premier jour
que des donc était malade elle le savait
juste derrière je vous êtes parent
malade mentalement cas n'était pas
vraiment le même elle l'a avoué dans une
de ses lettres que je crois j'ai publié
miens j'ai voulu coûte que coûte la
soutenir et jusqu'au bout jusqu'à la
dernière minute j'ai essayé je me disais
j'ai comme théorie que si chaque homme
parvenait à rome un autre rue en
autriche ac est parvenu à rendre en
outre être heureux le monde entier sera
heureux un par personne de ce serait
déjà suffisant pour que le monde entier
et il en sérénité et le bonheur alors ça
c'est votre côté vous appelez votre
romantisme si c'est votre cas mon côté
saint-bernard parce que je suis né avec
ça
j'étais déjà comme ça à l'école alors
vous êtes romantique vous êtes parfois
naïf
là il est très live vous êtes timide ce
qui me paraît surprenant la vérité sa
vérité
oui c'est peut-être pour ça que quelques
voix je parle trop fort et je lève trop
fort la voix c'est comme tous les
timides
on a des moments où on explose savez les
colères temps en temps à mon jeu ça ne
m'est plus arrivé depuis 20 ans et
depuis je veux l'intérêt des agents les
pulls décidément il est extraordinaire
teresa vous aviez vos défauts c'est bien
parce que les sereine et je sais pas
c'est un saint bernard
aussi même si je puis dire 27 ans enfin
c'est une union vraiment comme jonny
malbon vous êtes romantique vous êtes
eyes est timide vous êtes bon tout ça
mais on fait pas bon je gémis défaut
comme toi il enfin vous êtes excusez moi
l'expression
vous êtes un vous êtes un drôle de
lascars avec les femmes parce que
vraiment vous êtes l'infidèle total il y
tout de même votre votre première femme
vous le racontez là aussi moi je m'en
aille c'est 500 go femme m'avait dit que
je suis gré voilà c est la 30è or comme
java bleue et très peu attiré par la
mort fait très très peu et je devais
prendre des précautions
je n'ai pas besoin de dire l'indiqué
lesquels qui rendait la chose assez
pénible par conséquent aucune femme n'a
jamais le temps est très autant tromper
de sa vie seulement sam humilié il n'y a
rien qui me un homme comme de devoir
mentir
en tout cas moi comme de devoir tricher
eh bien j'ai triché pendant près de 20
ans mais un jour pour raconter c'est un
jour elle nous a trouvé en fragrant
délit avec bourg elle nous dit cette
femme là où tu va [ __ ] à la porte et
médecins d'être fils il a déjà ça m'a
complètement gêné il faut dire qu'elle
sortait d'une famille bourgeoise elle
n'était pas du peuple comme moi c'est
cette finale gage dix ans cette fille là
c'est tout oui mais depuis lors nous
n'avons jamais plus le rapport mais nous
avons continué à vivre ensemble
d'accord mais on était très cruel à ce
moment là vous lui avez dit mais je te
trompes pratiquement chaque jour depuis
vingt et un ans et parfois plusieurs
fois par jour et oui mais je lui ai dit
ça justement pour que elles comprennent
que elle ne devait pas porter toute sa
haine sur bull vous comprenez je ne
voulais pas que ce soit bull qui
prennent tous les péchés d'israël sur le
dos et en même temps vous raconter une
autre scène invraisemblable
lorsque vous rencontrez des à new york
et bien voulu obliger parce que vous
êtes vous êtes fantastiquement jaloux
votre passion vous pousse à une jalousie
féroce voulu elle devant vous elle subit
lee a brûlé toutes ses lettres brûlé
toutes ses affaires même ajouté un
collier
enfin le donner à quelqu'un on me
donnait un prêt d'honneur comment avez
vous osé demander quand je dors là
j'imagine et encore qu'on pouvait
posséder quelqu'un que quelqu'un devait
être à vous je parle de l'oeuf et
l'omnium habillé penchard d'où les nus
je voulais rien qui comme elle avait un
passé assez trouble est assez comment
dirais-je
mais le vôtre oui le vent de passer
l'idée pas jurer que je sais mais
n'oubliez pas que ça se passait à une
époque qui n'était pas dans notre
n'oubliez pas que ça se passait il ya
maintenant
pardon c'est en 1945
alors vous voyez ça fait donc on est un
peu macho en 40 ans 45 on n'avait pas la
même mentalité vis-à-vis des femmes et
en 45
on espérait encore épouse ou bien c'est
tout à fait différent de la mentalité
d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ça me parait menstrues elle
vous permet à cette nuit mais ce que
votre comportement vous paraît
monstrueux aujourd'hui oui mais il était
tout à fait explicables étant donné les
idées de l'époque tout à fait normal
selon une idée de l'époque
et parmi vos amis il y avait charlie
chaplin et ona à sa femme il pleut
semble-t-il parfait temps parfait est
bon est ce que ce couple ne vous ai pas
envie que lorsque alors vous vous
débattez dans des luttes féroces
ben j'ai même écrit je crois j'ai dit à
chaplin
à charlie jeudi vous savez si vous
n'aviez pas épouser où là c'est moi qui
l'aurait épousé parce que là était la
femme était comme teresa c'est de la
femme qui lui a fait beau en tant qu'
cas vraiment été en union parfaite en
synchronisation si je puis dire avec lui
et des pas facile il était beaucoup plus
difficilement ne vous suit comment en
êtes-vous sur rue
j'ai bien connu je pense quand même que
vous êtes vous n'avez pas été si facile
à vivre que ça quand même
je crois que si je très facile arrive et
je n'en ai je respecte la femme j'ai
toujours respecté la fin dites vous bien
que même quand je pouvais avec des
prostituées par employé ce mot que je
n'aime pas j'aime mieux dire des
professionnels prostituées il sert à
quelque chose
les moutons et bien je les respecte et
je leur parlais exactement comme
j'aurais parlé avec mon ami seulement
par contre je n'ai jamais couché que la
femme d'un ami avec la fille d'un ami
avec la soeur d'un ami derrière tout ça
mais maintenant j'en sinon qu'on parle
de votre puissance
nous allons évoquer votre puissance
sexuelle maintenant votre la puissance
de votre mémoire qui fabuleuse dans ce
livre n'est pas de mémoire très peu
enfin j'ai la mémoire des faits dei
barrages surtout gens voient en images
tout lé fait les paroles mais par
exemple je n'ai pas la mémoire des noms
n'est pas la mémoire des chiffres on
n'est pas la mémoire du temps qui
s'écoule
pour moi le temps s'écoule presqu'à
plafond au même moment
oui mais enfin vous vous rappelez par
exemple les cadeaux vous avez à faire à
vos enfants pour noël il ya 25 ans oui
bien entendu
oui mais vous vous rappelez des
conversations vous rappelez bien les
odeurs des récessions alors peu importe
la chronologie ça n'est pas grave
médailles en or mais roman c'était la
même chose dit doug et tous mes romans
et en apparence louvre parle de
personnages que j'ai un temps non pas
seulement connue parce que je n'ai pas
toujours le même personnage mais j'ai
quelques voix 3,4 personnel que j'aurais
unique qui accable persona d'un même
type que je réunis mais je les connais
très bien je connais le décor très très
bien je n'ai jamais inventé un décor je
n'ai jamais inventé une atmosphère comme
disent les critiques
cette fameuse atmosphère non alors tout
ça ça de mémoire j'ai toutes les images
dans ma tête et quand je m'endors le
soir j'étais intéressant je vais faire
maintenant mon petit cinéma et il suffit
que je ferme les yeux et il ya des
images qui viennent qui bien qu'ils
tournent qu'il tourne qui deviennent
floues et je dors votre puissance de
travail qui a été fabuleuse vous étiez
vous raconter que à l'âge de 18 20 ans
vous écriviez 80 pages d'un dans l'apd
avec moi deviner roman populaire c'est
facile sur 80 pages mais cette mesure
est d'usagé de 6 heures du matin ces
genres du sauvage avec une interruption
d'une heure pour la cs car j'ai toujours
fait la sieste parce que c'est un gain
de temps on fait deux journées au lieu
de georges simenon vous raconter même
moment vous êtes devenu un écrivain
célèbre vous vous ne publiez quatre cinq
six romans parents comme les écrivains
gallimard de six romans s'en remet à
paris vous faites ça vous vous occupez
vous occuper des femmes
on en a parlé vos enfants d'une manière
vous en occuper sans cesse et vous
trouvé le temps d'aller faire du golf
tout le temps de faire la photographie
vous trouvé le temps d'aller au bistrot
où allez vous balader et puis vous dites
j'ai encore des eaux relie le port j'ai
fait du cheval j'ai fait du vélo j'ai
fait tous les sports j'ai fait de la
boxe j'ai fait vraiment tout ce qu'on
peut imaginer sport parce que je vous le
reconnaît tout connaître le monde entier
ou comprenez quand je suis parti à
l'aventuré à travers le monde et si je
suis particules presque tout le temps
car j'ai passé ma vie à partir c'est pas
pour rien que j'ai eu et on prend nos
missiles social 3e 33e
oui c'est que je voulais toujours
connaître autre chose j'ai cherché
l'homme nous font j'étais la recherche
de l'homme est bien longue
cj infâmes que je trouvais peut-être
parce que la femme est plus transparent
peut-être parce que l'enfant mon père on
peut avoir contacté
je ne peux pas avoir un calme alors ça
aussi c'est une curiosité et tout ça
sans se son magazine et comme sur une
pellicule si je puis dire ça c'est la
puissance de votre instabilité c'est à
dire toujours partir partir partir et je
ne fuyez pas parce que je suis vous
prenez des traités de psychologie on
voit d'irak partir c'est une fuite une
fuite en avant
et bien non je partais par curiosité et
si je ne voyage plus maintenant c'est
que je ne veux pas voir le monde tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui
je ne veux pas aller voir par exemple la
forêt vierge équatoriale que j'ai très
bien connu ou les [ __ ] était tout nu
et où il était tout à fait simple et
comment dirais-je heureux et qui n'avait
pas faim parce qu'il leur suffisait
d'augmenter un peu la terre de mettre
quelques graines de millet pour se
nourrir il leur suffirait d'une flèche
pour avoir de quoi manger matin et leur
foi tas de choses ont souvent l'étape de
société de consommation que j'ai déjà
nous sommes maintenant des marionnettes
dont les fils sont tirés pour quelques
individus ou plutôt par quelques
associations d'individus oui enfin jean
simmons et facile aux gens sont venus
aujourd'hui de vitupérer la cité de
consommation quand on a eu comme vous
des rolls des jaguars des maisons
fabuleuse et oui mais je voulais savoir
ce que c'était mais ne croyez pas que
j'en étais heureux unique j'en étais
fier j'ai presque honte quand je
traversais lausanne le maroc vous ai dit
qu'acheter des choses je ne pouvais pas
avec tout ce qu'il y avait à la maison y
avait sa voiture à la maison il y avait
deux chauffeurs y avait onze personnes
comme personnels par leur pensée avec 26
pièces penser que les pauvres vont vous
croire ben je crois je suis beaucoup
plus proche d'eux des riches en tout cas
mais c'est pas pour essayer de dire je
suis proche des pauvres en ayant vécu
comme un riche mais j'ai vécu d'abord
comme un pot j'ai crevé de faim à paris
j'ai vécu trois jours avec un camembert
j'ai vécu pendant cinq six jours avec un
petit meuble et ça se vendait dans des
petites terrine en terre des tricks
faramond parce que dans les tripes
faramond les réchauffe en entrant pendu
pendant peut manger un pan entier et qui
les cas où j'ai connu tout cela j'ai
vécu dans une pièce avec
une erreur qui était la moitié celle ci
et ça nous servait pour tous pour faire
la cuisine pour dormir et pour
travailler j'ai travaillé mais enfin ça
c'est cette époque s'est terminée à
l'âge auquel un 22 et 23 ans au no no no
7 rbs a duré plus longtemps que ça et là
aussi autres puissances qui est
formidable chez vous c'est la puissance
de notre curiosité de votre attention
mais c'est la curiosité simplement
cependant puissance je sais bien que
c'est plus tard défaut et ne vais pas
chez ces romanciers peut-être pas oui
mais c'est peut-être à cause de ça qu on
est romancé et vous fréquentez notamment
les bistrots
oui parce que c'est au bistrot
maintenant cordes ou les frais quand on
a 15 ans nous entrons dans tous les
petits nous connaissons tous les petits
bistrots lausanne
parce que là on a du coude à coude mais
nous n'aurons pas dans les combats si tu
les grands hôtels etc
nous allons mes petits bistrots de
quartier ils nous connaissent partout
dans les bistrots de cartes et ça peut
vous servir pour des livres prochain non
mais c'est un contact just d'un besoin
d'un vécu c'est à mesure nous avons des
copains à qui aura peut-être par les dix
fois mais qu'on cherche dans la rue
parce que il y en a a vu entre autres
avec un chien il est aussi les grands
chais et ils solitaire il se promène
tous les jours avec son chef et il
descend vers midi la base promener le
long du lac est bien quand nous avons
promené lors de la chronique est notre
copain et son chien on est on est pas là
maintenant
pendant quinze jours qu'on l'a pas vu
parce qu'ils sont chacun à son maître et
nous reconnaît ayez recours et jettent
sur nous ces histoires ont des tas
d'amis comme ça c'est un personnage de
simenon c'était avec son chien non ce
n'est pas un personnage ceci est un
personnage réel
mais s'il existe déjà la mort au mans je
suis persuadé que si on le il y en a
certainement un homme avec son chien qui
la nomme aussi l'ex aux chiens qui se
baladent et un vieil homme qui doit être
complètement confiance qui habite 3ème
étage d'une maison on a juste
l'avenue des figuiers et qui ne doit pas
pouvoir sortir de sa chambre je suppose
parce qu'il est toujours à sa fenêtre et
toute la matinée lorsque nous passons
pour faire une promenade on le voi sa
fenêtre qui joue de l'harmonica
il fait ça pendant des heures et le
peut-être at-il un peu dérangé
mentalement je n'en sais rien mais nous
considérons comme un ami et quand il
n'est pas là sa fenêtre
ça nous manque quoi considérez-vous d'un
côté les maigret et d'autre que tu es
des romans vous qualifiez de dur et bien
pour une raison
le roman policier a des rêves et des
règles sont des rangs comme d'arômes
d'escalier c'est à dire que il ya un
mort il ya un enquêteur ou plusieurs
enquêteurs et est un assassin longue et
une énigme donc vous devez suivre des
règles bien déterminée et en plus de
cela 6 au deuxième chapitre de votre
lecteur trouve que c'est un peu faiblard
il ira quand même jusqu'au bout parce
qu'il veut savoir qui a pu bon j'appelle
ça de la fabrication quand même et on
d'un semis littérature seulement que
l'employé d'ailleurs qui indigné jacques
emile blanche aux nouvelles littéraires
quand on se rencontre et à steg reste
époque-là on tenait salon dans tous les
journaux
tous ces messieurs nez avec leur canne à
pommeau d'or et la route forme et quand
j'ai parlé de ce militaire et bus est
mis littéraire qu'est ce que c'est et
bien si toutes sortes de fabrication si
vous voulez mettre fabrication et l [ __ ]
de luxe elle peut-être à deux premières
places troisième classe comme amenuisé
peut faire un à un ébéniste peut faire
des meubles bon marché et faire des
meubles admirable mais c'est tout de
même une fabrication tandis que ce que
j'appelle mes romans durs c'est pas mon
d'ailleurs kelly dur le premier c'est
tout simplement des romans ou capable
quand j'ai senti que j'étais capable
d'écrire en eau sans rompre
c'est à dire sans avoir telle et telle
règle à suivre
j'ai écrit ce que j'ai appelé mes romans
durs ou les dires du rat écrire non non
non non
mais dur c'est à dire je peux me
permettre de dire la vérité sur un
personnage dans les maigret au fond
n'est sauf vers la fin même mettant les
vingt dernières années
ils sont rapprochés de de plus en plus
de mes romans romans
alors je disais pas rebondir jeudi un
roman roman à l'époque net en s'alliant
les vrais sur les maigret vous les
écrivais directement à la machine à huy
est directement à la machine
j'écrivais en sifflotant ou presque mais
vraiment vous siffle ti en écrivant les
maigret oui parce que c'était face et il
ne va ce devenu un petit peu puis
vizille à la fin parce que j'ai un peu
confondu les maigret les autres néo
roman j'allais plus loin dans mes
personnages mais dans les premiers
nommés mettons dans les 30 premiers
c'était un amusement même à la fin
d'ailleurs je n'écrivais à maigret que
quand j'étais fatigué comme j'ai besoin
d'écrire mais je n'avais pas la force
physique ne mettent rarement parce que
vous savez c'est simplement d'une forêt
une résistance physique très forte en
deux heures et demie écrire un chapitre
de 20 pages dactylographiées
c'est fatigant un des vrais au monde
tandis que le maillage pierre notte
qu'est ce qu'il appelait c'est fatigant
intellectuellement non c'est fatigant
mais physiquement mais vous savez
intellectuellement non je ne suis pas
intelligent de 7,7 sortir ce qu'on
attend 500 on a dans le coeur c'est
sortir son instinct je suis un
instinctif je ne suis pas du tout un
intellectuel je n'ai jamais pensé un
moment j'ai senti un moment je n'ai
jamais pensé un personnage et sans qu'un
personnel ne va je n'ai jamais inventé
une situation
la situation est venue lorsque j'écris
un roman mais je ne savais pas du tout
où mon personnage allait mener celui
mené
et je vivais pendant d'abord 11 jours et
puis à la fin cette dans la peau de
personnages quand on dit à un jour et
c'est parce que jean-marie vos livres
souvent avait en chapitres et puis les
derniers ont eu neuf chapitres puis sept
chapitres exactement et sabrina je
n'avais plus la force de vivre 11 jours
dans l'état où j'étais nous parlions de
ma région tout à l'heure eh bien lorsque
je commence à un roman dès le deuxième
jour atteint la région 10 et 10 dans ton
personnage doit être un vieillard ou en
tout cas un type qui est pas heureux et
quelle mauvaise santé disait pourquoi
dis parce que tu marches maintenant
comme ça tout à coup tout cas l'air de
ne pas vivre avec nous le tout à fait
grognon et ses terrains elle devine et
mes personnages d'après mon identité
parce que toute la journée je restais le
personnage principal et cette histoire
qu'on a raconté qu'ils doutaient une
légende que vous portiez toujours la
même chemise dont vous écriviez c'est à
dire en taule
j'avais deux chemises que j'avais acheté
des à dire mon arrivée un mur qui était
très pratique parce que les manger très
large des chemises à conca en écossais
rouge et l'autre en est que ces morts et
ces chemises à maints avantages d'être
très très saoul est bien absorbé la
transpiration je ne la sentais pas coulé
sur ben pauvres parce que je sortais en
âge qu'un chapitre de roman toujours je
voulais changer complètement
c'était de la même chemise mais on
l'avait tous les jours si vous entends
bien quand vous écriviez quand vous
étiez en romans comme vous dites vous
perdiez du poids mais 800 grammes par
jour
teresa a fait l'expérience et la pesée
tous mes vêtements comme quand je
sortais de deux romans longueur montée
je me déshabille entièrement je me
doucher et je me changeais et la pesée
mes vêtements et sous-vêtements avant et
après mais le résultat 7 7 à 800 grammes
par jour
quels sont vos rapports avec mes gars
giec quelle est la part de vous dans
maigret et bien au début ils n'avaient
aucune au début je veux c'est d'ailleurs
change
la réutiliser var monde en deux ou trois
romans populaires car j'écris l'accord
des romans populaires et au sujet des
romans populaires je vous dirais je fais
une petite parenthèse c'est pour moi
c'était non seulement moins de gagner ma
vie mais c'est un moyen d'apprendre mon
métier car c'est un métier différent
roman on n'imagine pas quelqu'un qui se
met à composer de la musique sans avoir
appris l'harmonie et bien je ne
comprends pas que quelqu'un à 20 en dix
mois je vais écrire un roman sans avoir
hic vous savez que dans une pièce de
théâtre à jour sa plus difficile c'est
de faire rentrer un personnage et de
surtout de le faire sortir et bientôt le
roman aussi dans le monde il ya toute
une technique il ya un nom bien je
voulais connaître la technique du roman
et surtout savoir ce qu'il fallait pas
faire dans le roman populaire ont fait
tout ce qu'il ne faut pas faire alors
c'est le meilleur moyen non plus mettre
de sentimentalisme je dis pas ce
sentiment mais le sentimentalisme de ne
plus mettre de l'eau de rose etc enfin
tout ce qu'ils tiendront roman populaire
alors migré dans les maigret on en
demande et les romans policiers j'écris
des romans policiers
j'ai mis à un personnage maigret et au
début c'était une silhouette agronome
avec une pipe et un chapeau melon et
d'ailleurs il avait encore un corps à de
velours à son pardessus comme les
partenaires ce moment là et puis xavier
guichard qui était alors ce que pendant
le direct de la police judiciaire m'a
fait appeler j'avais écrite waro bon à
ce moment là et il m'a dit écoutez sinon
j'aime bien mon nom mais vous faites
état d'erreurs du point de vue technique
vous avez un petit peu
connaître toute la maison ici il m'a
fait connaître la maison et j'ai gelé
beaucoup fréquenté j'assistais à des
interrogatoires chansonnette
j'ai insisté avait arrestation j'ai
passé un mois à police-secours j'en ai
d'ailleurs tiré un reportage au journal
et j'avais ma voiture en battait qu'une
petit pastis allumé pour tel quartier et
qu'on annonçait un crime ou telle chose
dans telle adresse je sautais dans ma
voiture et j'arrivais en même temps que
la police n'ait pas j'ai dit étudier
tout cela mais pour mon plaisir en somme
wimille ça c'est la technique mais la
psychologie de migrer parce que maigret
mais est-ce que maigret a trompé sa
femme
j'ai même le monde mais je n'en parle
pas à vous ne pouvez pas ben non il ya
beaucoup d'hommes qui tombe leur vin
médias n'en parlent pas bon je vois le
mettrais je ne suis pas sûr que maigret
et était ravie l'évolution des moeurs
contrairement à vous euh je ne suis pas
sûr maigret vivait dans un ami vous
savez n'oubliez pas que malgré a fait la
voie publique
maigret a fait les métaux il a fait
grand magasin c'était comme ça se
faisait jadis ça ne va pas à l'école de
police qu'on apprend qu'on devenait
commissaire c'est en faisant plusieurs
années on commençait par la voie
publique
ensuite les métros ensuite les gars
ensuite les grands magasins et ainsi de
suite aimé que ce monde mais on notera
la criminelle ensuite et autre
différence est que maigret vous avez
quatre enfants maigret n'a jamais eu
d'enfant mais vous savez pourquoi une
raison bien simple quand j'ai créé
maigret je n'avais pas d'enfants et je
me sentais incapable de rendre la vie
familiale avec un enfant qu'est-ce que
je n'en avais pas j'ai une après j'en
avais il enfants alors oui mais il était
trop tard parce que j'ai dû dire que
megan pouvait enfin que le cul le ménage
maigret ne pouvait pas avoir d'enfant
alors j'ai dû garder mais grâce au
drapeau ou alors quelque chose qui vous
rapproche de deux maigres essai
l'attention de maigret pour les petites
gens à sa curiosité et sa sympathie pour
lever pour cette étape tout ça hein
c'est venu petit à petit couac tout le
même même dans pitre et tant qu elle
promis la maigreur de la sympathie pour
l'assassin et arrive même souvent avec
le lez plus ou moins échappé alors je
vais savoir aussi que lorsque vous
écriviez des romans et encore une fois 4
5 6 par an est-ce que les drames
familiaux vous pouviez vivre ou bien les
drames politiques du moment avait une
influence sur ses robes alors oui parce
qu'il me semble vous dites plutôt le
contraire dans votre livre c'est à dire
entendre nous est-ce que j'ai été
influencé par ce que je faisais presque
le contrepoint de ce qui m'arrivait au
lieu de raconter le drame que givet gens
racontaient un tous différents et
beaucoup moins dramatique mais j'avais
besoin d'écrire quelque chose plus je
vivais une période dramatique plus
j'avais besoin d'écrire que quand vous
écrivez pour le petit singe est un
astronome d'immigrés que j'aime le mieux
là vous êtes dans quel état
psychologique
habana j'étais dans la psychologie plein
de couleurs plein de comment dirais-je
c'était un pari que j'adorais le pari
des petites charrettes dans les rues des
charrettes à bras ou savez les marchands
des quatre saisons
le parent idéal et cetera le pari de
l'amour comme on disait à ce moment là
et que je connaissais bien parce que j'y
étais allé aussi quand on y avait encore
des clochards qui dormait sur une corde
et payer 10 centimes pour dormir
appuyé sur une corde et le matin à 6
heures le patron des tâches et la font
alors le show de chars savait qu'il
devait sortir du tout ça non mais
j'avais cru lisant votre vos mémoires
georges simenon qu' il y avait en vous
deux mondes bien différents le monde du
roman et puis le monde notre monde
après le roman dans le roman le monde de
la famille et que ces deux mondes
n'avait exercé aucune influence l'un sur
l'autre
c'est exact sauf que ça l'influent ce
que ça a existé et qui a existé qui a eu
c'est que quand
vivent une vie de remonter ou le pénible
j'étais beaucoup plus tentés d'écrire ce
que les autres moments autrement dit je
me réfugiais dans le roman donc le roman
était dans une toute autre atmosphère
que la vie que je menais et je la mets
je me suis servi ni de mon entourage
quels qu'ils soient pour mes romans
c'était pas ma vie j'ai quand je me suis
jamais mis moi même dans un dé personnes
contrairement ce que l'étape thèse et
d'intellectuels écrivent ils cherchent
la vérité team no de la charge dans mes
personnages ils n'entendront jamais ça
vous ennuie pas de ne pas mal prix nobel
et même finalement je crois que nous
avons n'a jamais prononcé non si je
devais d'avoir opté presque moins jeunes
il ya des gérants à peu près en 46 et
j'ai renoncé à ce moment là dans les
journaux c'est dans les journaux
américains ailleurs apparu un peu
partout que si on donnait nobel je
refuserais et pourquoi parce que je ne
veux pas de médaille je ne suis pas un
animal de foire lui sont les marchés les
taux vont nous donner des médailles
je ne vais je ne veux aucune médaille
les jeunes du grand écrivain qui ont
accepté modestement le prix nobel de
littérature
il y en a aussi qui lé thon faisait pas
beaucoup marché
je serai de ceux là si ça il fait mais
ça ça n'arrivera pas plus que je dois
annoncer la broye vous avez failli être
citoyen américain
oui j'ai failli tuer américain pour une
raison je ne crois pas aux nationalités
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que je ne me
suis pas naturaliser français lorsqu'on
me l'a proposé en 1936 ni non plus
lorsque mauriac
on a proposé s'est élancé et choses non
ces blocs notes mais
deux trains d'entrer à l'académie
française en demandant la double
nationalité j'ai dit non d'abord je ne
veux pas la double nationalité puis je
pas porter un costume de dark et soeurs
de banque car c'était le costume jadis
les enquêteurs de membres ne voient pas
eu
vous voyez qu'une épée au côté et un
chapeau d'envoyer pu mettre en prendre
le revolver vous avez porté pendant
quelques temps ap leur arrivée encore
boy dont je fais partie de la classe des
buts belgique parce que j'ai dû accepter
je fais partie des nih américain ils
passeront pose sa candidature on ne sait
même pas qu'on est nommé on vous l'a
dans un moment c'est parce que ces cinq
jours mais je ne vous êtes pas je ne
crois pas aux nationalités
pourquoi un jour et vous répondu à un
journaliste je me déteste
c'était en amérique et en angleterre
je me souviens encore en effet cette ag
du daily telegraph
et il m'a posé la question la dernière
question une autre sphère en longue
interview
et puis à la fin il me dit de i like
your self qu'est ce que vous aimez vous
même alors j'ai répondu honnêtement les
salles que je me déteste je mets et
c'est vrai qu'à cette époque là je
brisais c'était une belle époque assez
pénible
il ne sait pas que dramatique et je me
détestais avons l'attelage parce que en
voulant pas disant guérir quelqu'un
j'étais là je vous avais les autres vous
ne vous détestez plus de détails je ne
m'endors pas non je ne trouve pas un
type extraordinaire au contraire c'est
un homme comme halo de quoi est faite la
morale de georges sinon y'a pas mort on
est mal me croit pas à l'amour à la mort
c'est d'être sincère tout simplement
alors disons déjà clairement à tous et
la sincérité de la sincérité
oui il semble quand même moi
j'ajouterais la liberté à la liberté ou
de méchants ce n'est pas une norme la
liberté
malheureusement ça n'existe plus ou à
peu près la liberté dans le monde
aujourd'hui ea nous sommes timbré
naissance jusqu'à notre mort tout est
organisé
nous ne faisons plus que nous voulons
mais ce que l'on veut faire de nouveau
regretté que l'homme ait moins de
responsabilités qu'il y à oui si vous
aviez vu de tribus noires en afrique
elle et pretoria vous auriez vu la vraie
liberté même à tahiti avant que ce ne
soit pourrie par les avions et les
touristes etc
il y avait encore une liberté complète
il ne connaissait pas l'argent parce que
c'était moi je suis pas encore sûr prix
là vous me prêcher pour le bon sauvage
et vous n'avez jamais été un bon sauvage
quand même dès que vous êtes
dès que vous avez été célèbres ou à
paris vous avez couru les les premières
vous hésitez fêter ça pendant deux ans
vous l'avez fait pendant de départ ce
que je voulais savoir je voulais
connaître l'homme j'ai fait la chanson
rend toute ma vie savoir ce qu'était
l'homme
donc toutes les classes toutes les
catégories dans et pour les connaître et
ne s'agit pas seulement de lire du jour
nous de les voir de loin il faut faire
partie du groupe
eh bien j'ai fait partie du groupe du
tout paris pendant deux ans et j'étais
dans l'habit tous les soirs et j'allais
aux premières et au dîner de première au
souper première et c'est une autre de
vos obsessions c'est le refus du
maquillage détester alors d'ailleurs au
sens vrai comme au sens figuré le
maquillage
oui parce que je cherche la vérité
absolue
si je suis laid que cholet je ne veux
rien changer
l'idée c'est comme une idée de faire la
chirurgie esthétique
si même java année quatre fois plus
longue idée je ne ferai pas coupé ça
fait partie de mon intégrité
pourquoi le maquillage est ce qui est
assez extraordinaire c'est que vous
voyez que ça va aller très mal avec dès
le jour où ils recommencent à se
maquiller qu'exactement parce qu'on
accepte elle ne s'acceptent est plus
elle même nom non parce qu'elle refuse
aussi vos ouvre aux directives
elle ne veut plus vous obéir c'est pas
trop tôt c'est parce que elle a repris
ses cauchemars d'avant pensez pas aussi
qu'elle veut échapper votre tyrannie à
ce moment là ou non parce qu'elle
pouvait y échapper très facilement me
disant tout simplement jamais qu'ils
iront pour les points mais j'ai toujours
fait ce que boules jeu simenon le vos
mémoires intimes commence par le récit
du suicide de votre fille
je vais vous lire ces quelques bijoux
poser la question après sont évidemment
ligne dramatique vous adresser à
marie-jo vous dit ceci ton appartement
était dans un ordre une propreté
impeccable comme si avant de partir je
vais procéder un méticuleux nettoyage y
compris au lavage repassage de tes
vêtements et ton linge tout était à sa
place
toi même couché sur son lit un petit
rouge dans la poitrine et vous ajouter
ceci d'où venait le pistolet 22 à un
seul coup souligné un seul coup qui
avait acheté les cartouches
ces deux questions
c'est georges sinon le père de marie jo
qui se les posent ou est ce que c'est le
commissaire maigret créatures de georges
sinon je vais m'en réjouis parce que
c'est un sable suppose d'abord que les
donc bien prémédité puisque elle est
allée acheter en piste et où les
cartouches enfin je suppose ou l'appel
trouver où quelqu'un lui a donné je n'en
sais rien mais si j'insiste sur le
pistolet raku sais que je peux donner
l'impression d'être immigrés il n'est
pas tellement facile de satin dhr le
coeur exactement marrer je n'avais
aucune notion d'anatomie par conséquent
or un seul coup elle savait qu'elle ne
sera prêt pas donc elle a dû se
renseigner même peut-être ouvrir en
dictionnaire pour voir bien emplacement
du coeur à savoir la sainte église saint
maigrin qui à elle seule faire aussi
j'aime ou j'aime de reconstituer ce qui
s'est passé alors c'est les deux ibères
c'est plutôt le père je me rappelle
avoir lu votre livre qui s'appelle
lettre à ma mère
vous avez eu des démêlés avec votre mère
je me souviens qu'à vous allez l'avoir
sur son lit de mort il vous dit qu'est
ce que tu viens faire là t'étonner
d'ouvreur et pourquoi tu venais vu et je
me dis est ce que est ce qui n'était pas
aussi difficile d'être à la mère de
georges simenon que d'être l'épousé
genre sinon d'être le fils et la fille
de georges simenon je ne crois pas parce
que j'ai trois filles qui sont
parfaitement à l'aise dans leur peau est
parfaitement en temps réel avec noir ils
ont 42 32 22 ans ils ont tous jurent ils
n'ont eu aucun problème
de genre là ils sont absolument franc
sincère avec moi et n'ont jamais été
gêné les six n'ont pas été gênés par
exemple par votre personnalité qui
commettent très forte qui est du tout du
tout pas du tout non non pas du tout
aimé les jeunes n'étaient pas de son
vivant
croyez moi d'ailleurs
n'imaginez pas que j'ai une personne ne
défende je suis comme tout le monde dans
la vie normale mais dans la vie normale
je suis un homme je vous ai dit timide
et j'adore l'intimité j'adore la
solitude à deux ou en famille est née je
ne suis pas du tout en haut est ce que
votre réussite phénoménale n'était pas
intimidante pour tous vos proches
elle est plus intime mineurs pauvres
pour mes proches
caral matri 1000 go où ils vont si
j'étais directeur d'un journal mais
semble que je donnerais votre livre à
lire un critique littéraire pour qu'il
en fasse le compte-rendu mais aussi un
psychanalyste il ya déjà eu des des
thèses de psychanalyse non mais là je
parle de votre livre votre vie de vous
même nom nous a fait part lors de six
voix là mais on a fait des autres y
compris le pedigree etc
je savais qu'il ya plus de 81 thèse qui
court le monde
et certaines que j'ai d'autres que je
n'ai pas parce que souvent les têtes
sont simplement remis aux dix pays vous
savez il y en a une en angleterre qui
est 4 950 page vous ai marre et celui
vous l'avez écrit l'année dernière je
devais je vais commencer yal'état
touchés commencent l'année dernière et
vous l'avez revue aux dévôts printemps
et des années au printemps
alors est ce que vous diriez toujours ce
que vous écrivez page 559 on ne guérit
jamais de la perte d'une fille comme à
cherry et qu'il est sans vous invite que
rien ne remplira la vie continue certes
la même point d'interrogation
en effet la vie n'est pas tout à fait la
même
on m'a beau retrouver une certaine
sérénité hier toujours une blessure on
en regarde dans ses caprices toute sa
vie est évident que j'ai beau sont
clairement les jours avec nous de lui
parler il m'arrive d'en rêver mais
l'ascendant
pour moi ce n'est plus un drame eux ce
n'est plus le nomme comment dirais-je
matériel qui a eu lieu champs elysées
dans son appartement qui est toujours là
d'ailleurs son appartement est toujours
dans de tels qu'ils étaient le jour de
sa mort est ce que ce livre raconte
tribu et à recouvrer votre sérénité
peut-être peut-être ça m'a fait du bien
tout le même
enfin ça a été terrible je ne croyais je
croyais ci peut arriver jusqu'au bout
que j'avais fait une sorte de testament
en première page de test avant
supplémentaire parce que le testament
jackson de terre que si je n'arrivais
pas à le finir je chargeais telle ou
telle personne de le continuer
d'après tous les documents j'avais et
c'est quasiment la dernière phrase de
votre texte ou dit ceci
vous vous adressez là encore à marie jo
tu es toujours dans notre jardin où je
te rejoindre est un jour parce que dans
mon testament celle enregistrée après
l'incinération cela que teresa hier à
répondre mais sans la devant le cerf et
cible un goût et mario mais alors qui je
veux dire qu'avec qui qui dialoguera
avec marie jo et georges simenon là on
veut l'enterrer en tout cas chaleur avec
elle marie jo dit le vent devront
peut-être
[Musique]